[Music]
hello how are you how you feeling how
you doing Ron Simba with the music I
might lose it oh yeah Sims on the phone
Sims on the phone Sims on the phone Sims
who's the most famous person you've
texted in the last week like who's a
name that me and fens are good to go
wish I had that number in my phone
Matt Damon no Johnny it's it's probably
a coach what level of coach coroner had
a head coach in the last we know of
you've heard but I'm kind of a big deal
we know that Oh Winston Bello check on
son I'm telling you anything I only have
one question yeah
which conference the NFC or the AFC yeah
my wife is just texted me saying there
was a flying squirrel in our house in
the house in the house how did it get in
I don't know we're talking like full
limbs stretch with like webbing and my
wife said it was cute as hell she got it
out yeah I didn't even know there was
flying squirrel only in the sims
household is a flying squirrel in the
house cute Charlotte I was gonna say I
would have been facetimed with yelling
oh my gosh this three L's mandibles
gonna beat me there was a scrub a
scrunchie or a squashed cockroach in the
Train and I thought it was like oh god
oh my god get it away from me
it was like this one she's saying she
sent a picture of that oh not either
yeah that's cute
see this is what happens left go and I
planned the podcast and we go the intro
two minutes then we're talking about
death and then we got a flying squirrel
in the house and next thing we know okay
all right you ready want to talk about
death let's talk about death baby let's
talk about you and me let's talk about
all the law balls in the end zone that
dizzle catch Josh what did he get signed
signed oh yes right Josh what group sing
that song that means I'm just saying I
don't know
I saw papa let's talk about sex so you
didn't know des guts I know officially
now left coast number one take away my
closet okay chill number one take away
that I took about des going to the
Saints yes
I love Sean Payton and I love the Saints
for this reason yeah you beat the Rams
everyone crowns you the king of the NSC
you are celebrated all week long and the
first thing you do after the game is we
have an issue with our third wide
receiver position I let's improve right
and I got to see the Rams and they're
really good and I'm not sure we can beat
them that same way again
there are some teams that will rest on
their laurels and there are others that
will go let's admit where we are weak
and fix it hmm what are your first
opinions about distance perfect fit for
Dez great job by him very fortunate that
this opportunity came about from himself
because I mean I you know he was he was
in no-man's Ville here I mean if they
don't get him all two tickets to no
man's mailman not no man's land no man's
Ville okay and I yeah I was wondering
whether he was gonna ever be able to
sign to a team but I do think he fits
really well with Saints first of all
like New England he's gonna walk in
there and go okay they win they don't
need me so I don't need to rah-rah do
breezes giving the speech exactly right
I don't need to command the football or
anything cuz Michael Thomas is better
than me Alvin Camaro is better than me
and they have Drew Brees he's better
than me as well but and take some hills
better than and he's very good but yes
they have a third receiver out I mean
I'm still at the point where I see
number 80 on the field white boy supreme
car and I'm like wait who is this guy
who is this guy over here that so they
really needed yes because Cameron
Meredith like I told you I think on
Monday has never truly recovered from
his knee injury with the Bears last year
so he hasn't quite got up to 100% and
they do truly need him and I think he
fits with what their offense is I mean
they are again not a bombs away defense
and I know people gonna go boy there was
72 yard touchdown yeah but it was really
it was like a 25 yard row right and then
he was open after that that's where they
lived they live in that you know 15 to
30 yard range of throws and you have Dez
Bryant and Michael Thomas okay so you
want to double do you want to double
Michael Thomas oh okay great that's
great but you know then you have to deal
with Dez Bryant who's widely known as
one of the best 5050 back show
ball catchers and juries invented is I
don't know Sims did honestly really I
would say phil simms but that down the
phil simms questions for when he's only
by the way phil simms is bad back so he
invented what do you yeah ok let's save
all right we'll go to it later but
either way so what you're saying yeah to
what you're saying is you're still right
drew brees is the greatest back shoulder
back shoulder thrower there is I mean he
start I don't wanna say he started way
he did start the wave this recent wave
he definitely did their Holston and all
the wake up and think about those guys
those are guys again Marcus Colston you
know 15 right 50/50 guy oh he'll run
over the middle and catch tough balls in
traffic right that's what they look for
it's multiple it's what they do on
offense and now you can't just
pigeonhole one guy to go oh he does this
and he does this I think you're seeing
that more around the NFL more now than
ever then going you know the old days we
have the guy that goes fast and we have
the guy that goes underneath right no
now it's more of like we have Robert
Woods and Brandon cooks and Cooper Cup
and they all do the same thing and you
have no frickin clue where they're
coming from right and I think that's why
he fits well there it's I this could be
do you think it could be a big signing I
think gonna be impactful I do I think it
cuz the name seems impactful yeah I just
didn't know how impactful it'll be for
them no I I do I think that you know it
they'll take it slow but he's gonna find
a role in this offense mm-hmm I will say
this I do like the fact that Michael
Thomas is a michmash problem yeah Alvin
Kamara is a mismatch problem right and
then you add somebody like des even if
it's just in the red zone yeah and I
also have to say this I can't imagine
des has got to be hungry as hell right
now and this was like the dream this is
what he's talked about I want to go to a
contender a team that's gonna be
involved this is where he can now again
if things go right set the market for
himself the way he likes to get off this
year yeah well I should know what he's
gonna be with the Saints that he never
got with the Cowboys a chance to win
playoff games yeah yeah right which is
also gonna set him up with I'm saying
for the bigger payday but yeah it's it's
uh it really is cool and the Saints just
you know if you got to quickly break
down their offense in their past attack
right
it's slants yep it's in cuts over the
middle yep it's deep crossers
and it's back shoulder or fade balls and
wheels
yeah wheels right which is what I almost
called back shoulder okay ball it's kind
of the same type of concept in retro but
yes a development side through right
right where if he gets on top of them
it's a go route and where if he's up the
backers on top of him it's a back shot
my only other question about des yeah
you know Jerry Jones probably has the
Bleacher Report app he gets the alert
that des signs with the Saints yeah how
do you think Jerry's reacting to this I
don't to his former coach Sean Payton
right who was in the Cowboys
organization his team on Monday night
scores 14 points against the Titans what
do you think Jerry's thinking with Dez
signing to the Saints to an offense
that's really capable yeah I think he's
thinking oh no this could get really
thrown back into my face here has to
yeah because once the cowboy it does has
a December right where all of a sudden
it's like man Dez is getting like six
catches a game for 85 yards and Alan
hurt we let him go I don't understand it
and that's that's what will happen and
it'll be the conversation I just wanted
to see really quick before I moved on
how that how that comment do owner it
didn't do well something happened to it
oh it got bumped out yeah it got bumped
out all right man smiie and federic
polluted comments on Instagram what were
you guys doing we just I commented under
this desk picture that Jerry Jones was
[ __ ] his pants oh I wanted to see
how it was good sometimes I like to call
my shot and go this will be a three
thousand like comment cuz we got pretty
good at it yeah all right let's go back
to basic Sims Constitution Aaron Rodgers
is the greatest quarterback we've ever
seen we had an experience with Landon
Collins on the show check it out YouTube
Sims love for the show and oh yes
Eastern Wednesday nights very good a
p.m. with YouTube and to be our app
where Landon Collins told us that we
said you know who's an offensive player
that sticks out he went right to Aaron
Rodgers yes and it made us happy and he
told a story about Aaron Rodgers
giggling and looking at him he gets to
the line of scrimmage he sees Landon
standing in a certain spot and he laughs
and Landon goes oh crap starts running
back immediately too late Davante Adams
touchdown then apparently the McCourty
twins had a similar story this is Viet
Tom Curren in New England Jason McCord
II said that from Sunday's game Sunday
night's game yeah early in the game
Devin McCourty and Doron Hartmann were
disguising something but they got out of
it right before Green Bay was about the
snap and he said that Rodgers saw it and
he held the snap as they backed off and
he was laughing so Aaron Rodgers
apparently is looking at defensive backs
in the NFL we've now heard nothing at
them two different defensive backs or
different rows going he'll half set up
yeah
have you ever laughed at anybody no have
you ever heard of quarterbacks laughing
at anybody well yeah like Cam Newton
last year like oho you like that oh you
study film you study this yeah because
only the physical freaks of the world
can play the game like that you know
again they can have fun and be good cuz
they go damn I'm so good this is fun
it's like the backyard oh Sunday Night
Football is here grain is awesome I'm
still gonna be awesome
oh you're Blitzen ha that's cool I'll
get to the right check we're like hey as
awesome as a Peyton Manning and a Brady
are they didn't have that physical
ability to just be that they're counting
Millie the millisecond they are there
more than kin huger right exactly right
it's computer and I gotta get to this I
gotta do that I gotta continue well I
mean we're gonna get to it yeah there's
a lot of disguises that you've noticed
in the third there is a lot of disguises
there really is but I've seen instances
like this with Rogers during games where
you know he smiles or he's pointing out
the mic and he looks out and like you
just catch a close-up or whatever it is
and yeah that's you know I always go
back to my dad was like the first one
that ever taught me that I was like oh
yeah I mean dad Michael Jordan just like
smile isn't that funny because well
Christopher when you're the best player
in the league it's easy I mean he can he
can enjoy it and that's what those kind
of physical freak guys can do any
defenders smile at you like you like I
want to cancel out the stories you've
already told ya know okay know about
Zach Thomas and those guys calling out
the play I know about Ray Lewis you know
going it's fun here I know
Edie Reid kind of read like baited me if
you tell you thought he's gonna pick me
he's like no I saw you even though he
might
anyone anytime else though that people
were just smiling
Tedy Bruschi I can remember playing New
England and I started to be like damn
they're all I started to like mess with
my hands underneath the center cuz I was
trying to do stuff like that
he was communicating a few times and I
knew I'd like a dummy snap count out of
that booty 5 booty buys hot and he was
like get ready real quick I mean look at
each other he'd like he'd smile like
little moments like that certainly we're
like humanity somehow humanity to the
grid I didn't like brueski was like oh
you you caught me stressed out there for
a second that's good right yeah oh damn
I'm gonna sack you anyway so yeah you
did sack me yeah those are ones that
jump out to me but like other great star
players that I played it with like
Brandon Marshall and his prime he could
be like that you know oh well you know
okay he might once he got the ball cuz
he was angry until he got the ball but
then once he got the ball he could like
you know he'd watch a receiver cut or a
DB come up and get ready to jam I mean
look at him he like laugh point at him
like you think Jamie great good luck I
feel like we was like that Steve Smith
said that I mean he could talk the guys
I told that story right I don't know if
you did Steve Smith Carolina 2005 it's
I'm starting down there and I see South
in the early tooth honestly good was
some of the best [ __ ] ever because the
characters when those teams were absurd
hoppers Vic Steve Smith alright it was
it was good our team had a ton there's
but he came over to the sideline unlike
a third down and he ran over and Gruden
sitting right there and he goes hey
group watch me [ __ ] your DB's up and
then he caught a first down and that was
like and spend it on the ground and like
you know of course crew did loved it
actually he hated it but he loved that
kind of like that's right right you know
we all loved it we were all sitting over
the sidelines like damn that's awesome I
I wonder when Aaron reached that point
where he went
I'm confident enough to smile and stuff
like when did the game slow down that's
what I'm always curious Super Bowls wins
Super Bowl wins at an early point of
your career can lead to the flourishing
of greatness does that make sense the
pressure is gone the press
I'm at number two Kyle Shanahan is our
favorite coach in the NFL look man you
always got to bring it back to where you
started by the amendments Nick Mullens
the kid continues to make me laugh
quarterback I did about tell wanting
Kyle to shut the hell up in the headset
[ __ ] obsessive/compulsive Shanahan
shut up alright so here's the quote and
then Sims you break it down this is from
David Lombardi the athletic apparently
Kyle has a no-no so Nick has a one-way
radio in his helmet where he hears Kyle
obviously Mullins was so ready to call
plays versus the Raiders that according
to George kiddo he kept saying does Kyle
ever shut up in the huddle will Hal Kyle
was still talking Kiddle said the entire
Niners huddle exploded and laughter
whenever Mullins jokingly talked back to
Shannon because obviously Shane so
Kyle's like all right don't forget that
you're gonna the slot and it's like
alright Carl that's great so first thing
I totally understand Kyle over talking
yeah this kid has net the fact that this
kid is never play in the NFL before even
though all these stories are coming out
that he's kind of a savant yeah and he
knows the offense you told us better
than any of the other quarterback it
makes sense that Kyle's going don't
forget to look off the safety and then
also you have the check down below along
right but that's so Kyle so Kyle Heath
it's really Kyle's more stress than the
actual quarterback who's playing in the
game cuz Kyle's like listen my plays are
perfect yes right don't mess it up don't
mess it up in the huddle I mean Kyle is
you know again what I call a good psycho
he's a he's a great
psycho he in the best of ways but the
offense is his baby he's
obsessive-compulsive to like to a fault
at times cuz he's that crazy and yeah
he's probably saying the play in his ear
twice and then giving them like two
reminders about the play and Nick
Mullens is being like dude well it's
like let me just say it to the team so I
could have more time to line of
scrimmage to read the write or say a few
things to a few guys as you break the
huddle
you hate shift at the end here don't
forget to keep the D it or hey wait
before I motion you I'm gonna give you
the like there's little things and
always go one eye
see a quarterback look to the sideline
and with his hands go come on come on
right are they what are they typically
saying is that them going down and out
faster tell me the play faster we're
taking too long I want more time on a
little bit more time all right and then
what do you think about Nick Mullens
signing us to the team you like it I do
yeah it's it's not like you know those
are things where it's not disrespectful
to the coach it's not it's not it's not
disrespectful the coat Kyle and I
haven't talked to Kyle I would be
shocked if that was the way I did this
stuff to Gruden where I mean you can go
back and see games where I'm in the
huddle doing this cuz I'm going waving a
ball I'm going shut the in the huddle
going shut the [ __ ] up I can't even hear
myself talk cuz he's telling me you know
Falcon right tight shift a week right
why right h3x bingo why smash for the
third time and I want to be like I
[ __ ] got it did I've studied all
morning I studied all last night and a
five nights before this you've had me on
a chalkboard seven different times
during this week writing up plays you
make me get in front of the offense and
say place so I don't mess them up I got
it that's like let me play so you know
what Nick's going oh definitely and
those things too like what I guarantee
when Kyle hears that they're like
they're like ah Nicholas Nick was wrong
as my last question right is we know
Kyle yeah is Kyle gonna be sensitive
about this no it's gonna be not at all I
think he's gonna look at it he's gonna
smile and go okay this it's that's more
about moxie thing and ooh this guy well
this kid I think has it he moxie on a
number of levels
yeah one the fact that he's a Southern
Miss kid right with Brett Favre and he's
got a little bit of that accent yeah the
post that we put up of him yelling to
the team right you could tell the team's
like I kind of like this kid a little
bit yeah he's got some chutzpah it's
fine moxie
it's moxie is the varsity blues of foot
spot yes so yeah Johnny but that'll be a
thing where like even when Gruden that
you know I know guys told them that I
was kind of like saying those things
he laughed okay yeah he's my soldier you
know yeah he's got he's good he doesn't
have been my other question is yeah do
we have a quarterback controversy when
Jimmy G gets back Oh
we're not there yet we're not there yet
not there yet but no I thought I thought
that was a really really cool story you
saw George Kittel was so excited that he
got followed by Travis Kelce oh I
already talked to our producers I said I
want to go and hang out Travis Kelce
with George kiddo that'd be cool right
yeah I mean Kittel is I think maybe the
the most loved guy on the 49ers team
everybody loves Kendall yeah we were
there like we love him yeah of course
you could see it he's a hard worker he's
honest and he loves football he he has
the Grunk
quality about I can block and I'm not a
soft tight end yeah but I'm a really
good receiver and I'm just a bro yeah
I'm always here for a good time you're
never gonna have George kid all in the
locker room with his head in his hands
be like what's wrong and be like just
not feeling it today you know he's just
it's a good guy to have in the locker
room because you kind of go when does
this turn off yeah all right so I
haven't seen this yet and I'm a little
bit nervous
me and Josh went out got a cup of coffee
and I said you know he was like I want a
power rank the teams and I go I'm always
more interested now that we're nine
weeks in yeah who is even capable of
winning the Super Bowl
yeah so I'm gonna caution all of the fan
bases right now Raiders fans that hit me
up on Twitter and say lay off you're not
winning the Super Bowl
Niners fans where you are maybe the
Cowboys you're not win the Super Bowl so
if you don't hear your team right now
fast forward it could hurt your heart
I'm sorry we are naming and you came up
with a list and I didn't know how many
teams you were you're gonna have you
thought I would come up with nine that's
not what you thought my I just didn't
know how many teams Sims to you believe
are actually capable of winning the
Super Bowl this season right what's the
total number I believe 10 you believe
through nine weeks of the year yes there
are 10 teams which means there are 22
teams not capable of winning the Super
Bowl
plus some playoff teams that I don't
think are gonna be capable and Josh just
blacked them out I literally can't see
them I purposely let it go kid I do not
know right but I want to go it's the
rare time that left go wants to go one
two time doing that you know Google Doc
for real nerdy but I don't want to go
ten to one because I think the story
here is who are the teams that can win I
know that you think the Rams they're
your number one team right so we're
doing reverse Power Rankings for the
first time in my life okay I've fought
for this so you believe that the Rams
are the number one team right now in
sims's power rank they are I still I'm
gonna put them as the best team in
football I just think with those weapons
Aqib Talib will be back healthy the
addition of Dante Fowler you know again
I know everybody's gonna look at it go
man their defense though it's scary yeah
okay it's scary but they don't you know
they're this is Wade Phillips he's not
into like leading the league in and
yards per game you know they know the
concept of what their team is a lot like
Kansas City they don't want teams going
on 14 play drives for nine minutes they
want to go we'd like our offense back on
the field make a play or give up a play
and let's get this game right number two
yeah the Patriots yes sir yep the New
England Patriots
you know after those two out of the
first three games la la losses I mean
well what can you argue about the
defense has come alive they do the
proper things on a weekly basis they're
the scariest team in the NFL right they
got a good I thought about making them
one but I thought about with them
against the Rams hmmm I think that is
one matchup where the Patriots actually
like just right at a surface level I go
ooh that could be trouble even for Billy
ball game in that one number three yeah
run game the Chiefs not the Chiefs Wow
not in the top three and boy do they
look up you're going Saints at number
three yeah I'm gonna go the Saints over
the Chiefs I mean again the Chiefs are
awesome too but I just go the Saints
it's still Drew Brees the toughness of
that offensive line you trust their
defense their defense a little bit more
than the Chiefs I do and I just I looked
at that when I go like all right so if
they had to play head to head would that
be a great game they'll get me wrong I
go I think I just have to take like Sean
Payton Drew Brees and the toughness of
their team in that matchup boy do we
like doubting the Chiefs all year wrong
but you know what it's not doubting
Chiefs are set up for a decade they
don't need to win it this year by the
way yes go ahead I guess I'm gonna go to
this you have the Chiefs at four right
I told you guys yeah six weeks ago it
happened this happened this happened I
can't [ __ ] happening right now
the drew brees MVP campaign even though
he threw for a hundred and twenty yards
in a win two weeks ago
forget about Gurley forget about mahomes
I'm seeing NFL Network I'm seeing all
these people going
it's a Lifetime Achievement Award he's
never won it before
Patrick mahomes like what he's doing
right now he has 29 touchdowns in eight
weeks he's gonna break every record he's
on pace to break all of the records yes
but yet Drew Brees
I just Drew Brees is in the top three
he's in the top five right right now for
MVP voting but he is not number one
no know what even close oh and yeah I
mean like just study to watch it happen
and I hate how people say that too like
oh you know okay the you know Lifetime
Achievement Award Oh Patrick mahomes has
years to go you don't know what's gonna
happen no idea Dan man Dan Marino played
in a Super Bowl a second year and he
said I'm gonna be back here a lot and he
never went like shut up with that crap
you don't know yes that's bullcrap it's
it's insane to say he has the potential
to win more yeah this may be his best
chance you thought that the not you the
proverbial you the Royal you thought
that the Dallas Cowboys with dak and
Zeke we're gonna have 10 times more
chances to get a run at a Super me right
I don't know if they're gonna get one
you get another playoff how quickly that
turn has tape right oh you know that's a
good thing you know the MVP thing is
that there's really a good comp
conversation though I mean of course
mahomes and Gurley are still at the top
of the list for me you know who do you
go from from there like Oh Darryl
pattern I'm just gonna throw a guy's
like Phillip Rivers deserves to start
being in that conversation yeah okay I
mean he does he deserves to be in it at
least man Newton yeah Cam Newton a
hundred per site right and then drew
brees I think those are the guys think
I'm not gonna put Matt Ryan they're four
and four he's doing some awesome crack I
feel like I'm more predicting that in
like when they win like three of their
next four or something like that all of
a sudden like they're in a playoff that
he can be in that combo and then do not
forget about 80 don't just kidding
alright I haven't seen number five yet
number
five number four we did the cheap seats
are for okay
yeah number five is the Carolina
Panthers yes siree Bob
I would say that right now your top five
is I let me just see is number six the
Chargers it is not it is not alright
then don't reveal it just yet I didn't
look all right number five is the
Panthers come here a little quick
breakdown well the Panthers are number
five the defense is very good okay it's
still Kuechly I think the thing that
separates their defense this year from
yours pass and I know we've talked about
a little bit is the fact that Bradbury
is on the edge and Dante Jackson they
could play more man this year than in
years past Dante Jackson yes ran a 4-3
to right went to LSU right and he's
currently tied for the lead in
interceptions that's right he's a baller
the Panthers are really good at drafting
mid to late round they are really good
and look at Cam Newton the weapons they
finally have on offense their old line
they found the right combination two
guys haven't after dealing with some
injuries early on yeah I think the
Panthers are definitely the fifth best
team in football and number six the team
that they faced off with on Thursday
night the Steelers you get the Steelers
over the charger I do that was a tough
one that really was I really went there
with just more of a proven commodity
thing like the Chargers have blown a lot
of football games over the last few
years
others do find a way to win those tough
ones they really do I just thought about
not a big man right if they had to play
man if they had a play game first game I
just go man Big Ben it doesn't matter if
he's playing in LA or Pittsburgh he
don't give a damn yeah and Antonio Brown
and Mike T you know again you know that
they he's really freaking good too and
what they're doing on defense is really
good I just realize so yeah I'm gonna
make a prediction yeah that at some
point either at the end of the regular
season or in their playoff run
Anthony Lin is going to get a little too
conservative in a very big game so I
want you to save this in book market
Anthony Lin I love as a coach great
interior offensive line run game
believes in strong defense protecting
the ball Tomlin knows how risky you
gotta be unfortunately this is gonna be
my Chargers prediction yeah Anthony Lin
gets kind of tight
and that big game kind of reels it in a
little bit and that's the reason they
losing it yeah that's my that's my
November seventh prediction we haven't
seen them in those situation and that's
why I feel a thing because your point
there about the Steelers Tomlin has been
there battle test their battle tested
yes as you the Chargers number set and I
also look at the charges and go like the
defense when you talk about ok the great
pass rush then that that Steelers Oh
lines good because they're not gonna let
like bozo and company just ruin a game I
would have a hard time believing that so
that's why I just gave them that I can
see this being an experience gaining
year for the Chargers alright so now
we're getting to the teams where I don't
know who you're gonna pick yeah I don't
know the order so we have three teams
left that you believe could win the
Super Bowl
yeah listeners it's your team one of
them could you reach behind you and get
the Oracle really quick I didn't realize
that either even I just thought if
you're going to be doing predictions the
Oracle must have his crystal ball number
eight Sims look towards the future
who is your eighth team that is capable
of winning the Super Bowl this year uh
hold on I forgot what I have is eight
guys Philadelphia thank you very much
yes
so you think the Eagles are capable I do
too I do I look at the Philadelphia
Eagles as okay they lost some games
early on they didn't play their best
football Nick Foles was in there Carson
Wentz's back he's been playing in
awesome the last few weeks even the
Carolina Panther game he played awesome
I know he did he threw the pick at the
end but I looked at with the addition of
Golden Tate what you guys got up front
on both sides of the football
yeah I look at this team is still one of
the best teams in football I think
ultimately they're going to win the NFC
East they play a lot of these teams that
are in front of them and they get the
face from the play right they're set up
to get in I really do and once they get
in man to me I just have a little bit
more faith in them than the two teams
that are gonna be behind them I'm gonna
say this right yeah I am very cautious
when I usually talk about the Eagles
yeah I usually bet against them because
I don't want to jinx
right I bet against them to start the
season I had the Cowboys winning the
division and that hasn't proven to be
wrong yeah and you know what that's okay
cuz predictions are ridiculous I am
saying this right now the Philadelphia
Eagles are the defending champions and
they're about to go on a run to remind
everybody and it's going to get ugly the
Eagles are about to go on a really
really pretty run right now and I want
to state this for the record the Eagle
is a lot of record Eagles have the best
quarterback in the NFC he's better than
Drew Brees he's better than Cam Newton
he's better than Jared Goff he's better
than Matt Ryan okay Carson Wentz is the
best quarterback in the NFC they have
the second best defensive line in the
NFC yeah they have the third best
offensive line in the NFC and I'm
telling you right now that the cast of
characters that receive the ball is in
top three in the NFC as well
now with Golden Tate Al Shean Zach Ertz
that is a really good mismatch for what
they're trying to do yes but one thing
that everyone's sleeping on right now
Darren Sproles his bracket practice
Timmy Jernigan Oh Timmy Jay mark Michael
Bennett Fletcher Cox or about to remind
all of you fools who is the defending
champion yeah you're 19 capable of
winning the NFL's championship the Super
Bowl you have the Vikings I do capable
of winning the Super Bowl I do
Wow yeah I mean the defense is still in
the conversation from one of the best in
football what they do just with their
front four of course the secondaries
awesome the linebackers are good so they
have the capabilities on any giving day
to really make life hard on any offense
and you know again their offense as a
whole is that as good as last year
but they are turning the corner in my
eye a little bit the run game has come
alive I've no I think I've said that
like three podcasts in a row but I do I
believe it I could see it and between
that and what Kirk Cousins does throwing
the football yeah but
and digs on the outside I give them a
chance to win the Super Ball I mean not
that that I would put money on that but
do you see them as capable they are
capable they'd have to fall into the
right matchups and certain things like
that but yes it's it's it's a
possibility
we now have one team left yeah that
yardage is I do not know is cable do not
show it to me yet I am sitting here
looking at five teams okay give me here
and I want to hear what you think
here are five teams that you are picking
between that could be the team yes are
the Packers capable of winning the Super
Bowl are the Bears capable of winning
the Super Bowl or the Texans capable of
winning the Super Bowl are the Ravens
capable of winning the Super Bowl are
the Seahawks capable of winning the
Super Bowl I'm looking at these teams
right now I'm not even saying the
Bengals I'm not even gonna go down and
say the Jaguars I'm not even gonna say
the Titans right now you have one spot
left
yeah and there are five teams that I
think could be an interesting argument
Chris Sims who is your 10th and final
team that that you believe is capable of
winning the Super Bowl does Shawn Watson
the Houston Texans now it seems so
freakin awesome yeah so oh and why would
you delete that so ok you don't think
the Packers are capable now you do not
believe the Bears are capable nope Wow
yeah yeah it's just they're not ready
yet it's too young of a football team I
can't put them in that Cravens you're
selling yeah done just can't do it just
just get it captain don't have the power
and the Seahawks no dice Seahawks it you
know yeah it's just
Seahawks could be a problem and they can
maybe sneak into the playoffs thank you
no playoffs maybe upset one team along
the way I just don't see how they could
do that I don't think their defense is
as good as what everybody thinks once
again but the Texans have all the
necessary pieces an amazing front 7 yes
secondary that tackles well and can
defend an a defensive coaching staff
that's smart enough to drop them back
right they have an offensive line that
you believe is outperforming and you
have a quarterback that can do anything
in a wide receiving core they can get
right forget it yeah the Texans are made
for playoff football they just have one
problem yeah I mean it's Bill O'Brien
gonna come up with an offense yeah it's
scary I hear you that's right you know I
read your nose I know yeah that is that
is a big issue though yeah that would be
the biggest question about their
football team is just if they have to
play other great defenses can they come
up with enough plays to you know scheme
some things open it can't always be
Watson and Hopkins making unbelievable
plays and catches what do you want to
say something no no they're gonna take a
deep breath but they are yeah they're
they're made for playoff football I mean
us you know they could make a game ugly
against Kansas City and then okay damn
Kansas City and mahomes he's tricked and
they're doing all these weird things on
the DJ John cloudy and over here Pro
right and they're getting pressure and
then you go oh yeah I forgot Kansas City
Steven sucks it's - Sean Watson and they
can run the ball and they got hot Miller
hop right yeah they could do that and
you know they could be a pain in the
butt for like a Patriots team as well
you know we have seen the Texas exact
Roxboro right in the bud right let's
talk about Monday Night Football because
the Cowboys the team that we had winning
the NFC East were eliminated but guess
what I don't want to talk about the
Cowboys really we have this thing in our
country there are a few teams the
Cowboys the Steelers the Raiders the
Patriots yeah that when these teams lose
by 14 even though you beat them by 14 no
one talks about you at all all they talk
about is damn this team fell apart this
is a Titans team that is four and four
they have they were like one decision
away from maybe upsetting the Chargers
and being five and three yeah and most
importantly their to know in the AFC
South they've beaten the Texan right and
I don't think any of us are sitting here
going the Texans are gonna go on a run
right now if anything we're going the
Texans are gonna come back to earth well
guess what they play the Texans again
they play the Colts twice they play the
Jets at home they play at the Giants and
home against Washington yeah they're the
Jags one more time - right yeah but I'm
saying out of conference yeah we're out
a division they could be the Giants with
the Washington just die that's a win jet
should be a win that the Colts twice
yeah that's five yeah now you're nine
and four yeah I get you
easily lose to the Colts twice - they
absolutely could yeah but I'm just
sitting here looking at one the
storyline that the demise of the Cowboys
always outweighs the success of shall
the Titans were on a bye and Maury Otis
finally running the ball and wow I like
the way the last two weeks they've been
using Dion Lewis in third and fourth
quarters to move the ball down the field
and man there goes Corey Davis again
stretching out and a defense like and
that that pass rush with Harold Landry
getting the deck at the end of the game
yeah all we want to talk about is
Malcolm Butler sucks yeah and the
Cowboys are imploding right it's just
funny to me it is funny and it's not you
know hey Malcolm Butler certainly has
not been as good this year as he has
other years but again I just like
everybody to recognize with Malcolm
Butler just look how many times he's
playing man-to-man in the face of a
receiver he probably plays a man-to-man
and island as much as much or more than
anybody in football we assume because
we've played Madden right that you can
put man-to-man and he's gonna be right
there well that's right yep you should
stay with Amari Cooper he only runs
forward has the whole field to run
around your phrase is there's like four
to five guys that would ever be put in
that position yeah
one day maybe next week I'm gonna have
you write down those four to five okay
that surely get left on an island right
but how difficult is it as a corner to
be man a man with no safety hell I mean
okay can you put it into layman's terms
like we've said this about Marcus Beaton
well we heard we heard like Nate
Burleson the other day tell us that like
you know Randy Moss was you saying bolt
with shoulder pads on I mean wide
receivers are the freakiest people on
the planet we heard Landon Collins tell
us the freakiest guy way yes whose
freaker's sake want a row down he
basically said Odell they're both freaks
but he said Odell dunk on Dell would win
at a dunk contest it there these are
extremely gifted fluid it's like out of
this world
explosive athletes that he's beings
they're saying hey that guy that's um
the quickest guy in the five states
surrounding us and one of the fastest
guys and also those five states we'd
like you to just go out there
and like a cheetah just you know run him
down like he does a gazelle all game
long and if they try to throw him the
ball just stick out one of your paws and
knock it away it's no big deal right no
big deal okay okay yeah sure
and and he can go left he can go right
it goes everywhere far you can go stop
because you have no help no you have no
idea where he's gonna go no you think
about Monday night the the first
touchdown in October
oh yeah now all right like what do you
call that madam when I was playing is
called as a growl it could be it's a
return route is what I would have called
it it's a return route like a return
slant you're running a slant and then
you're returning back outside right
highlights Cooper's cuts on Monday his
cuts are going back to the first day we
saw him in training camp member we saw
him go up we were like oh my gosh that
by the way before you get to that
touchdown yeah his first slant where he
kind of went out a little bit and then
slant is that a normal route I mean
where'd he just make that up yeah he
makes it he's got like out of this world
Hall of Fame potential type route
running that's what I was so excited
about him when he came out cuz the
corner just was like yeah what do you do
and if you're just a quarterback and you
start to get used to his guys like and
then he starts doing like a little hops
guess and any cuts that go he's and
Alan's the king of the hop right but he
is he is there's a few teams there are
few receivers and football that do that
right oh yeah yeah they change up their
body language and you're just like him I
don't know if he's gonna go straight
here or right or left but on that place
specifically with the slam returned like
Malcolm Butler's fine you know there was
a mental mistake that was a mental
mistake think about the play back if we
even go to a highlight right now Kenny
Vaccaro was sitting there inside for the
slant he should have been outside
leverage you right you did not need to
follow him that way I texted you and I
was kind of joking right it's it's as
though like Malcolm Butler was like
disrespected by Bill Belichick yeah and
every play he goes this one's to prove
you wrong bill like he's so aggressive
on the show there's the ways you have to
you have to account for the mental
mistake though i account i account for
it for sure like it's just been little
things like that all year even with the
other double move for the touchdown like
he knows better not to like yeah
quarterback yet he's just he's he's
little technique things and little
intricate details of what's being
coached in the meeting room he's
getting caught up in the game and going
I gotta get Amari Cooper and he's forgot
that the call there is there's somebody
gonna be there for the slant don't
follow them in you know you get caught
up in the emotions of the game and
you're covering this freak athlete and
you forgot oh damn on this call I didn't
have to go inside with him and I did
dammit and I feel like that's what's
happened to him a number of times so
Cowboys are dead
yes dead I think so I mean I had a hard
time thinking they could really like if
they could sneak into the playoffs okay
great like hey we're gonna make a run
not in my eyes mmm Cowboys are in a
first I'll give Troy Aikman a lot of
credit for what he said I wanted to know
what you wanted to think about a copper
hero a lot of credit I mean that's
that's not an easy you don't hear do you
think Jerry Jones was treating troy
aikman that well
cuz i'm gonna be real yeah Jerry seems
to love these recent guys more than the
older guys I'm always seen him around
Romo and Witten and all that stuff I
don't know if Troy was getting that
Jerry Jones love I don't know I said
it's not that okay I think Troy is just
heats I think he's really trying to send
a message to Jerry I think he's trying
to I think he's going I love the Cowboys
Jerry just as much as you and he's
trying to politely say you and your
family are the problem I know that's
what he's trying to say he was trying to
say that likes Ivan Jones and all that
stuff like you're not picking the right
guys you're not doing the right stuff
look when I watch the all or nothing and
it's the Jerry Jones family tree he's
sitting at a table with his daughter and
his two sons and they're the ones
planning everything for the Cowboys from
the halftime show to the coaching hires
to the draft picks it's for family
members in a room yeah those are the
only fingers that you can point at and
go they're responsible they have found a
guy in Jason Garrett who's a very
respectable guy that's willing to let
them have that control I can't imagine
there's a lot of head coaches that are
gonna go I'm okay with this situation I
have said many times they're in the
Monday morning meeting
yeah Jerry wants to be able to go to the
media and explain it because probably in
his mind I can explain it better to the
media than the coaches can and I want to
say that as I
always said before Cowboys fans the
writing was on the wall every NFL team
runs how the NFL owner ran their former
company Jerry Jones made his money in
oil let's go and dig over there and see
if a Maury Cooper can give us oil let's
dig over there and see if there's
anything left in Roy Williams or
Keyshawn Johnson or Joey Galloway let's
dig some oil in that Jaylon Smith let's
try and dig some oil with Zeke
everything there's no plan it's not
connected I imagine that's how you dig
for oil Jerry Jones made his money as an
oil tycoon and he's running the Cowboys
the exact same way
Oh Jason Garrett you did good in those
seven let's dig there for eight more
years and then when the well is dry you
blame the well yeah it's the guy diggin
and Jerry you're not that good of a
digger no that was good ya know the but
that's how he runs the team it is well
there's like two things you know first
of all I like to like remind Jerry first
of all that they won three Super Bowls
when he did have a guy that had a plan I
mean I know Barry Switzer won the third
one but that was still Jimmie Johnson's
team that he had won with and he got rid
of him because I think the plan
intimidated no doubt he wasn't in on the
plan Inc back I'll give food for thought
for everybody else here on this just to
tell you what Jerry is Jerry wants pawns
as head coaches not head coaches first
of all as a player on a team you need to
have the head coach has to be the power
guy you can't the head coach can't be
calling the team up and the player be
listening the head coaches and going way
does that really what our things or is
that what Jerry thinks so there's always
gonna be that I also think about hard
knocks they're building Jerry's world a
few years ago when they were on Hard
Knocks and he had a construction guy who
was building the stadium and was giving
Jerry a hard time and if anybody
remembers correctly he literally goes to
the construction guy hey I just got rid
of a coach he was always giving me a red
ass cause he was talking about Bill
I don't need another one like you and
I'd to me that I was something I always
took out in my brain that yeah you know
bill was in charge
Jerry Anna take a seat in the back and
listen and you know take notes and I'm
sure Jerry learned a lot but it killed
him to do that and as soon as he got the
opportunity to go I'm out of here I'm
gonna do this he did it and he's yeah
it's not a coach problem always it's an
overall cultural problem that's what
Troy Aikman saying the John's do some
good things there what they've created
is very respectable and they had the
knife or Talent
they do have an eye I mean DeMarcus
Lorenson yes you know all these other
free defensive linemen they have
whatever now right they gotta look for
what they're looking for but they need
someone else to be the head of planning
and then they can just interject every
now and then and give sir two cents you
know what they need
yeah a Josh vendrick they do Johnny
Google Doc yes one other coaching thing
here so Hugh Jackson apparently an
interview with shefter said that he's
absolutely willing to join another team
staff this year if asked as an assistant
and I have an out of left go field I
believe he should go and work for the
Bengals and then next week work for the
Texans and then the week after that the
Panthers the Broncos the Bengals and the
Ravens you know in the NFL when it they
a team signs a player cut by a team and
they milk them for all they can get why
can't huge axon just go and work for
whatever team is playing the Browns that
week right get like a week-long check
where he goes in there and he goes look
for this and then look for that and then
look for this then you'll be fine and
give him like a nice hundred thousand
dollars and all right now you're on to
Houston and now you're on the Carolina
why can't we do that we do that with
fifth string wide receivers and four
string linebackers bring in Hugh Jackson
gave me the cues for what Baker is
looking at here break down the best way
to block miles Garrett is that crazy I
mean it's it's not actually I mean yeah
I mean I know there is some legitimacy
that it's I guess it's like you know
it's the code every that's not protocol
don't give away my Sandra takes me back
to
little movie called Billy Madison oh
here are you is this ethics okay the
thing about business ethics is think
about business ethics is called that guy
business ethics there was a little dog
he went into the forest
I've wasted our time one of the things
so you're just gonna dismiss it know
what I mean I don't I don't I think like
it actually is a good thought right and
why couldn't you pay him to be we bring
in Chip Kelly in the offseason to learn
hurry up offense right why don't we
bring in a Hugh Jackson for a quick now
breathe them round off those teams are
gonna look at the rounds ago we don't
need you be we're gonna be okay yeah so
that's the other part of it but it is an
interesting thought you're right I mean
I don't know why you're right well you
can sign the guys off the practice squad
and the fourth corner to bring you bring
them in to get a look into somebody
else's playbook or a check or whatever
it is yeah why wouldn't you do that
that's actually not out of that far-left
Cofield there thank you also out of the
left go in field out of the left go in
field also like I just set the Gerry
thing one more thing just come out and
say you're gonna like what you're gonna
extend dak Prescott like dak Prescott is
not worthy of an extension right now
firstly dak Prescott is gonna have to go
to year for next year and still prove it
at least to me again hey I see some how
is it so good that first year and so
rough right now because that was like
one of the greatest running teams that
we can point to in recent history I mean
that was they were like a slam dunk
guarantee to go well we're gonna whoop
your ass upfront and it leaks gonna
piledrive his way through there and
he'll break one eventually and then deck
yeah you need to hit four or 50/50 balls
exactly and by the way you got Dennis
Jason Witten right and ologist that's
all it came down to so yeah but I mean
that that to me was a little bit of a
crazy comment to like again that's not
what a head coach should be doing or a
leader of an organization at this point
you know I I think a look at the Cowboys
and go you know that they should be in
the mix for guys that are to bring in
their next year the Joe Flacco's the
Jameis Winston's like that should be
like you kid you miss Winston on the
you can't be the most ridiculous thing
of all time I just as it looks right now
and if dak has an awesome end of the
year here then I will certainly take
back what I say and go no dak proved to
me he's the guy and they go in with him
next year but the way things look right
now I go hmm it's just too inconsistent
there's too many dumb mistakes bad
decisions slam dunk like should be
completions that are missed and they
either got to bring somebody in to
compete with them and to have like a
poker in his ass a little bit just to
drive them or or even move on I don't
know
Jerri though likes coaches there are
gonna chap possess he likes quarterbacks
that are gonna kiss it and dak has done
an amazing job at becoming best friends
with Jerry Jones and that's a testament
to him yeah well I one guy that might
not be coming back at all apparently is
Le'Veon Bell the athletic apparently
found a new clause in the CBA in which
Le'Veon Bell does not have to come back
this year and it still counts as a year
towards his free agency I don't know how
one week before week ten a new Clause is
discovered in a contra it's all about
the language in within it I've read some
of the language you know many nerds and
media there are from your other co-host
Mike Florio to the Andrew Brandt's of
the world that their entire job
description is I'm a former lawyer I'm
diving into a contract to provide
content for the masses how is it not
going discovered until now Florio's been
rate you got I'll give Florida please
Lauri owes been raised not to the night
I'm blown away Gloria's been raising the
question that this there could be a
fight brewing here because the language
is you know soft for lack of a better
phrase where he's lost leg you know
where he can be internment internment
interpreted like two different ways
where I guess it's a little finicky as
far as saying yeah he should still be
able to yeah you know be a free agent
after next year but it is also a little
bit there that's like oh he should be
able to get what franchise to
again unto the quarterback number it's a
little bit wishy-washy there where it
seems like they're gonna have to bring a
third party in to clean it up Le'Veon
was seen in Pittsburgh playin pick-up
basketball right I wanted to come back
because of what we talked about on
Monday to be great I will be shocked if
he doesn't come back so but here's what
I wanted to do we talked for three years
Simms about a player sitting out a
franchise tag for ten weeks it's been
our dream yeah Le'Veon Bell did it yep
and I want to do not a self scout but an
analysis of we've talked about this for
three years it finally happened what was
the experience like looking at the media
hmm a lot of people turned on levy on
the team turn so let's just remove levy
on and just say player a yeah
player a sat out ten weeks yeah it
started off with his teammates calling
him out his coach has come out and said
and this is a very players friendly
coach came out and said I want
volunteers not hostages the media kept
going we went through a plong period I
think we're still in it where we looked
at his backup and because he was
serviceable we said we don't need this
guy anymore we have him so we degraded
his impact and I would even say that the
most player friendly show us we even
turned on levy on for a little bit I
just think it's interesting that here we
have a guy that's trying to maximize and
so many levels people did attack him in
that 10 week span and it's just
interesting like this is what we wanted
someone to do and even us we got a
little bit annoyed because a little bit
we want him to come back yeah and then
also you know when someone sitting out
for money reasons it's really easy to
call them greedy yeah we ever called him
greedy or anything like that I don't
think we ever crossed the line I'm just
going to be one of them back just
because we wanted him back and we like
them like Pittsburgh what did you learn
about a player sitting out 10 well I
learned that first of all everybody has
their own agenda that has nothing to do
with them so shut up that like oh well I
think you should
he's being selfish he should shut up
you're not the guy this is his life
probably draft him in fantasy this is
his life and you haven't played running
back in the NFL and this is what he felt
was best to further his career and
secure some money so as much as we want
to get frustrated about all that you
know I just think we've you know there's
too many other elements there that are
at play that people aren't being
realistic about you know hey yeah the
Pittsburgh got away with it why okay
because Pittsburgh's really good nobody
makes up what one Peyer does not make up
a team on any team other than number 12
in Green Bay like really that's all I
can really say about it it's a team
sport okay yeah they have Antonio Brown
and Judy Smith Schuster and a great
offensive line and all that so they've
been able to weather the storm there
because of that other talent there you
know and that has helped kind of turn
the tide against him my gosh see you're
not that special
James Connors just as good no he's not I
don't give a damn what you say he's not
as good as let me on bail he's real good
so I want to say this is what I realized
we have seen a lot of holdouts the only
holdout in the NFL that I believe
actually worked was the referees kam
chancellor didn't get as much money as
he should have yeah the preseason ones
those aren't really holdouts Larry
Johnson back in Kansas City did get a
good contract but the only water Ahnold
you're not counting because it was
pretty didn't miss any regular-season
games
Emmitt Smith Gotti what he got wanted
back in the day but I was gonna say
though the only time that I felt like
America didn't villainize someone but
instead said we need them back was the
[ __ ] referees yeah that was the only
time where we had sympathy and we're
like see see every other time they were
like this guy selfish or this guy could
do it just as well or by the law but you
couldn't deny it with the referees
because the guy cuz Russell wasn't threw
an interception on national TV and they
gave it a Hail Mary touchdown yeah and
that was it we're like what he's a ham
Chancellor like the Seahawks secondary
got torn up those first two games they
did right yeah right but it never got to
the point where they were like oh
they're screwed without them like it
just never went
they're even like we heard one time
where people went the referees are
selfish no you're right they never
didn't either had never heard that never
happens all right never seemed to happen
well I think it's kind of cool that we
talked about something for like three
four years and it actually happened I
didn't there I never thought this von
Miller to do it it sounded like he was
ready to do it they got like 50 million
guy that wasn't they realized damn our
defense is really gonna be in trouble
without them yeah I just uh levy on
props to you for doing it yeah whether
or not it was the right decision we'll
learn in free agency with your contract
we'll see how you do it your next spot
and I I can't remember a guy in his
prime having a year of no contact ya
know even next year I'm curious how he's
gonna come out if he doesn't come back
I really would be I got to think he even
thinks that is he in the ball he isn't
the ball he's gonna be back next week
okay he'll be there Monday afternoon
that's great yep I see him I said all
right let's dive into the film no look I
make sure that I really kind of I I
summarized all of your notes we're gonna
go through the team's a little quickly
okay
Texans Broncos go ahead Texans offense
yeah big things that I noticed from you
right the Texans offense is too simple
at this point yeah you wrote they need
more quick throws every pass can't be a
huge gash it's too simple for when they
played good defenses they need more pick
plays the Broncos were all over the
Houston offense in the second half yeah
they're me needs more versatility like
within the offense itself it needs more
they need to find more short easy
completions a la New England with
Edelman over the middle little things
like that they miss that element they
miss they need more wide receiver
screens they let too many times and big
situations Denver just got in their face
and played man-to-man and they tried to
run you know an inn cut a worker you
know come back and Denver secondaries
good and they could jam them and disrupt
the timing then all of a sudden you know
he's like oh wait I'm ready to throw and
they weren't quite there yet and then oh
damn here comes von Miller and I got to
dance around and now I have nobody open
you know yes they have to make this has
been bill Bryant
bill O'Brien's mo for a while I think so
it's it's definitely like the
the biggest question question I have
with him and I do think he just has to
expand more in whatever shape or form
he's just got to give defences a little
bit more to think about not a lot
because they have talent and they play
tough and they gonna run the ball but
they do become a little predictable and
they can't always just say we're gonna
we're gonna overwhelm you because we're
tougher and we got to Sean and Hopkins
you were impressed by the old line again
you think DeSean Watson is now finally a
hundred percent but one thing about
Denver's D you're seeing situations that
you go how can this happen right and the
one that you circled and all that stuff
was how does linebacker Josie Jewell get
matched up one-on-one with DeAndre
Hopkins there's just too many situations
like that going back to the Jamie versus
Denver defense issue right where I
complained about how can the linebacker
be responsible for the tight end man
demand but also the Aged also the a gap
that's and then all of a sudden the
tight that the coordinator realizes that
and they make the tight end run a route
to get him out of there and your coaches
vantage Joseph yeah who was a DC yeah
right is that a Vance thing yes
definitely is it is definitely a a Vance
thing he's got to be able to do whether
I know Joe wood is the D cordon area
right but they're they're both in this
together he's got to see those
adjustments during the week and go you
know they just got to do it they got to
look at it and go damn we're asking a
player to do something that's way
outside of his comfort zone and it is
really just stupid and I'm gonna get us
fired at the end of the day we need to
change that you know why they felt
comfortable Josie jewel why it's a story
that we had this offseason it was a whoa
big offseason because if you remember
right
Josie jewel was the one that raised a
hundred and thirty cattle and 18,000
turkeys back in Iowa look the kid can
handle a lot of stuff yep okay great
Texans defense looking at your game film
yeah you have a man crush on the Texans
defense yeah overpowers you you said
that Jadeveon Clowney is the best Rover
you've ever seen yes what does that mean
a rover is you know how we watch a
Texans game and we see him stand up and
walk around in the middle linebacker
position and you're just like oh gosh
here he comes
which guy is he gonna pick to run over
and go get to the quarterback
he he he [ __ ] up so many plays in that
game I mean yeah I think he only had one
sack I can't remember exactly but I'm
pretty sure but damn did he Glatt was so
close and four or five other players or
ruined running schemes because of that
his ability to just overpower people for
a guy that's not like built like a
Khalil Mak he's kind of more lengthen
and wiry that way the power is through
the roof and yeah he's amazing at it
because he has great straight ahead
speed and great power you also had
another compliment about another Texan
you wrote Kareem Jackson is the best
tackling cornerback in the NFL yes this
is two weeks in a row Uriah and praise
to Kareem Jackson I love watching Kareem
Jackson Kareem Jackson and honey badger
in that secondary that's like can't miss
football for me because they can do
everything and I just respect you know
Kareem Jackson allows them to do
different things with their defensive
front where they don't always have to
ask like the defense and our outside
linebacker to set the edge right you got
to set the edge they can sometimes go no
JJ go ahead and shoot the C gap inside
and you know
Kareem's really good on the edge will
play zone and if he sees the run he'll
make the tackle and he doesn't just make
tackles he he like is a heat-seeking
missile and I I appreciate that about
him I want to say this about the Texan
yeah Jonathan Joseph has been out right
yes the Texans defense he has been
crushing they're getting Jonathan Joseph
back soon and Aaron Colvin yeah how do
you combine those two right with Kareem
Jackson and honey badger and that front
seven there's a reason they're in your
teams that are able to win the Super
Bowl
a team that left go picked before the
year yeah yeah
that's a good one man and I feels good
it's got all the pieces it does they're
all they're up there with him
I had them beating the Patriots in
Foxborough yeah we did our playoffs I
mean it they are a team that are capable
of doing they are and uh I I don't know
they might be they might be my new man
crush they might have overtaken
Jacksonville on defenses of the AFC
South yeah
last thing about the Texans D you did
say sometimes they over complicate it
too much but the comment about Denver's
oh he said Keenum did all he could do he
didn't play grow gutsy as hell homestead
their button is a beast yes you said
though that Vance
you should have advanced the ball at the
end of the game ticket the field goal I
mean just like sure the way Kenan was
throwing on that last Drive I just yeah
they complete a pass to get to like
second and two I want to say on maybe
the 33 yard line 32 yard line and
there's like 32 seconds left like damn I
didn't know this day and age kickers are
just guaranteed to make 50 yarders come
on I'm brandy McManus has missed a
number of I mean just I just that that's
not acceptable
it's just not especially with your team
and some of the things they've messed up
I do I think they dropped the ball he's
been having a few more plays just to get
four or five more yards like there was
no reason to do that the thing that I
want to say is we always use the
Patriots as the gold standard yeah they
are working all the time if you're not
working all the time don't be upset
realize that that's the standard and you
got to work up to it right when Aaron
Rodgers work the ball down the field
with 40 seconds left and no timeouts
yeah and got a 25 yard field goal for
Mason Crosby that's the gold standard
right if you don't want to go for it
that's fine but just realize that were
allowed to come for you right now
because we saw this season what you're
supposed to do to help your kicker exam
or not you're not coaching yeah that's
what you're not dying now Washington
Atlanta hmm I don't know if you saw
these news today about Atlanta Atlanta
is now 4 & 4 yeah you know they signed
Bruce Irvin I did ok yeah is that gonna
be a big deal I think it's um manat
that's a huge deal this is where I look
very complimentary about the Falcons
deal if Dawkins d-line is is already got
good depth and his sneaky a pain in the
ass especially when Grady Jarrett's back
healthy so and to Karras McKinley back
healthy again right but Bruce Irvin is
just like Vic Beasley where he could
play dn and be a pass rusher but if you
needed him to be a stand up linebacker
and do
that he can do that too and it's just so
valuable for that defense because
they're not overly creative in the back
end and what made Seattle great back in
the day was they could send droves and
just waves of fresh pass rushers of
people at you to where yeah it's not
that complicated but you're not gonna
have a whole lot of time to sit back
there and dissect it now I don't think
you know this no you knew who showed
back up at practice today what person
Dionne Jones oh I didn't even know they
play as a linebacker I didn't know that
Dionne I thought Dionne Jones and and
Keanu none of them were done for the
year
I didn't realize yes I art right I
didn't realize yeah so now you got Bruce
Irvin for more depth and Dionne Jones
and your four and four yeah and Fenric
when I read Sims us notes
let me just read them all off yeah good
Falcons d-line is healthy and deep he
still has speed man they pieced it
together the Falcons are not dead they
have found the right combo of players on
defense to give them a chance and to let
their offense carry them I don't think
they're gonna make the playoffs but I
give them a puncher's chance I do you
thought the Falcons old line is handling
the Washington D line very much crazy
cuz they lost both of their guards yeah
but you're looking and then the biggest
compliment you wrote Matt Ryan is
earning his contract it's official for
me he is a [ __ ] baller showing he can
carry an offense he is a top-shelf
quarterback yeah definitely I just want
you to know yeah I'm reading your notes
yeah
I'm synthesizing yeah the Falcons have a
chance I know I know they have a chance
they're gonna be a pain in the butt they
might have dug themselves in too big of
a hole I'm still not gonna sit here and
go their defenses solved I don't know
what they're quite dominant enough to
where they're gonna be able to still
overcome some of the things they got in
the secondary and things like that where
you know again I know it was an
impressive win but the Redskins is
checked down Charlie it's no weapons at
receiver that was a good matchup for
them it was a very good match right into
Grady Jarrett with Adrian Peterson
exactly right no Chris Tom so Jason is
falling apart in front of us Jordan
reads example Josh Dotson I've given up
on that I mean all right right I wash
jock stocks I go no you
you're a fifth round pick it's it's it's
over so like you know that was I don't
want to be a prisoner at the moment but
I do like what I see from their defense
and of course it still plays hard and
the fact that they are so deep on the D
line is great and damn yeah Brian is
officially one of the five best
quarterbacks in football it's every week
I go man and third down he found a way
to make it work this cool it was pretty
and some of the other guys but then he
escaped the pocket and through a through
a laser - Calvin Ridley I mean he is
capable of carrying the team to a degree
I know he's got some weapons around him
but it's still it's impressive what he
has done to me this year the last year
were better than the 2016 MVP season
they really were because he's wasn't
given he was given so many silver
platter plays with Kyle and that offense
that year he's had to earn at these last
two years and he's making plays that are
not drawn up in the playbook and he's
still making it happen and that's I put
a lot of value into that you guys know
that if he was playing at this level
with Kyle what would he have done yeah I
know I thought about that but I also
thought did Kyle setup the jumping point
for him to do this - to finally give him
the confidence and everything to just go
I can I can he's always capable right
maybe I just I yes
but it's uh I yeah if that was the case
you know maybe he doesn't get hit as
he's about the throw and the Super Bowl
well maybe maybe evades it right right
but things are so easy they just wanna
say this is what impresses me about you
like I thought when we started doing
this podcast that all right we're gonna
be a bortles hating Rogers loving Matt
Ryan hating podcast you know because
sometimes that's how shows work yeah you
go we don't like these people and we
like those people but the fact that you
can watch the film and go I'm a Matt
Ryan guy now yeah appreciate that man
thanks man
good [ __ ] trying to take bias out of it
I'd do my best yeah you're a few bias
about a few people actually pitch that
idea to Josh earlier that we're gonna
come up the list of people that were
just openly biased okay
all right like like like like I'll just
put this all right now I can't
objectively talk about say I'm Donald I
like Sam as a purse it's hard so like I
have a hard time yeah and that's
my bias I'm just telling you my bias on
the other side though you wrote
Washington is done yeah Alex Smith you
wrote ninety million dollars for looky
routes for this I that this is one where
I go I don't know what a look around is
but I know Simms it's upset yeah I mean
you know WTF I don't know what else to
say it's his third and 15 and there's
two comebacks on the outside that are
open but nah throw that inside slant
route for a gain of six oh yeah your
complete your percentage is good what's
a lookie lookie is like it's it's a lot
like Michael Thomas does but it's like
the slot receiver has an option right to
if he has outside leverage he can run a
slant route if he has inside leverage he
has to kind of threaten the slant route
and then he comes back out court it's a
big like West Coast play it's more of
like the return route like you saw a
Marty Cooper race or you would sell the
slant to push that guy farther inside
and then you come out and catch the ball
and yeah I mean to me he just takes the
easy way out with those type of plays
too much like it's no one's gonna fall
for it fault them for it on TV or the
stat books not gonna say anything
because whoo there was the threat that
he might not hit that third and 15 guy
that everybody saw was wide open and he
airmailed it or through it as speeding
it then he becomes the blame this way
it's oh it looks like he executed what
the coach wanted to do there oh great ya
know what it is here is if the offensive
line would have blocked better on second
down maybe the third down would have
been a first one how to do that right
yeah I miss you go it was third and 15
what was I supposed to do right I don't
know I don't know look go for it look at
the guy on the other team who who was 10
for 13 on third downs cuz he was
aggressive on those plays and this is a
perfect example of why there are some
teams that tried to win the Super Bowl
and there are some teams that try not to
lose the superbright that's what he is
there are the teams that they come out
every year and they go all the teams are
created equal
it's like you start off with 400 points
on your SAT and if we don't make
mistakes it's ours until teams realize
that you need to go for broke yeah
you're gonna be eight and eight seven
and nine thinkin it's old thinking
lovely I don't know what a lucky route
song is I don't know what a look around
it is it's all thinking of that hold
what you're talking about it's just if
this is a new day day and age in the NFL
you gotta go win games okay so now I
need to pull up my text messages because
now we're gonna do Sam Brad and Arnold
who had come out was in a walking boot
and he is not going to be playing
against the bills which I'll be honest
there's part of me that goes see I don't
think he's hurt it's just an easier way
of bringing in Josh McCown Josh Allen
got hurt Nathan Peterman came in Nathan
Peterman in my mind should be saluted he
is the ultimate wingman no offensive
line Peterman's got it
no running backs Peterman's got it no
wide receivers Peterman's got it so that
when josh allen comes in they go thank
god he's not Peterman it's like you have
a friend that goes over and goes hey
ladies who's ready to party he's got two
thumbs this guy and then they're like oh
wow you're actually saying unlike your
weird friend right
that's Peter right Peterman's the
ultimate wingman they need Josh McCown
to be the old guy at the bar that comes
over goes ladies I got a 1984 Chevy
Malibu outside with your name on it
they're like what a creep Ivy's my jaw
yeah and then you're like oh I can't
wait for Sam Darnell to come back so
every backup quarter the hell are you
talking about
every backup quarterback it just
happened every backup quarterback is a
wingman and when I say by women not the
guy that's gonna help you talk to the
group of girls but the one that's gonna
make you look better in front of a group
of girls there's some new folk Nick
Foles can't hit an out route can't wait
til Carson Wentz comes back you know
what I mean that's the problem right now
at Nick Mullens too good of a wingman
Jimmy G's gonna come back and they're
gonna go oh hi Jimmy we love your friend
Nick he's gonna be like God
just get out of here man right yeah
that's the problem I give that yeah it's
not bad
it is the quarterback of quarterback is
I feel like that's what I was for
carried Collins like out you know he
might have missed the throw but I was
like ooh that was tough there was
somebody in your face and I'd sell it to
the coaching staff too like he'd come
over and what happened there and I pick
wah
I saw blah blah blah in his face and
they'd look at me Vic yeah okay okay
they'll move on to the next slide just
popping away my hair that's what you've
always said you can't have great backups
because if you're wingman's to good yeah
you become the way exactly okay Sam darn
'old I'm going through your notes here
your overall feeling about Sam Darnell
yeah after that game a lot of people
were coming at him I was getting a lot
of tweets going man the snaps were so
bad mm-hmm what kind of a situation was
Sam darn 'old in on Sunday against Miami
yeah everybody take a deep breath first
of all he's still a rookie you know gosh
it's a rookie with a team that is not
all that talented around him he doesn't
have any threatening weapons own talent
'add yeah it's a spotty offensive line
worth with should have been retired
Jermaine Coast curse as like his number
two receiver there that's exactly let's
let's do brass tacks down what weapons
are on Alpha know I know in coincidence
god she's just getting back from health
not healthy right so he's not doing
anything
Robbie Anderson's not the same as far as
that threat down the field can run one
round what you just said with the past
Pro thing that was a real I mean that he
had people around him all game long he
definitely did and also the offense
you don't listen I'm not gonna sit here
and lie I'm not blown away by it
and I also think they're trying to like
manage Sam too much and like Oh Sam you
know he came from USC and they got the
ball out of his hands quick and he threw
a lot of balls over the middle that's
great and fine and dandy great but like
in the NFL making a living like that
you're actually making it harder on your
quarterback
man just throw those quick routes over
the middle of the field against NFL
football players will think it's safer
yeah you got to be so precise and you
got to be able to trust receivers to run
routes exactly the right way and if one
little thing happens the ball gets
tipped in the air and it's an intercept
or you know the receiver gets hit as
he's gonna catch the ball and it pops in
the air and it's an interception so all
those things they have to be taken to an
account a little bit if Sam called you
yeah and said what could I do currently
yeah with the way that I play the game
yeah to improve what I tell them I would
tell him ooh that's a good question I
would tell him for one he's constantly
has to stay on his feet he's has such a
gift gifted athlete that I know we've
talked about this little just like if he
was standing on a clock for everybody
that's listening he can have his feet at
3:00 and 9:00 and still throw a pretty
good ball to 12 o'clock he did that in
the Lions right he can do that and it's
it's it's a definitely a good thing but
you don't it's you know you you don't
want to make a habit of it cuz you're
not gonna throw strikes like that all
the time you know that's the thing you
want to bring out when it's like oh damn
I'm in a tough spot here and I have to
do that and I'm gonna try to get it out
of my hand that way yeah he can do that
sometimes when everything's okay in the
pocket it's not a staple yeah it's
survival it's exactly so he needs to
clean that up a little bit the other
thing I would tell too cuz he can has a
tendency to miss especially downfield he
could throw a ball as high and over
people yeah he needs to get his front
shoulder in more he has to keep it in
there as he's getting ready like we
always talked about with creating
opposites and really get back there to
where you know you pull up coil up like
you see a Brady or Rogers where it
almost looks like they're nameplate you
could see the back of it facing the
receiver because what happens to him
sometimes and if you're seeing it on
videos like he can he can be like this
and I'll Stephen likes em I stand up and
he throws he wants to throw it this way
and he's like this is wide open and his
shoulders already out and then his arm
gets like this where his elbows low and
the ball he loses his power and I
imagine all of the strength that is only
on your arm I would think it would make
his arm sore at times because you're
taking away the coiling from the chest
now you're throwing all arm and then
that therefore I think gets him to dip
under the ball as we would say he dips
under it yeah and loses some control
there all I had to see did we get louder
or something did it get louder and your
you may have accidentally hit that
little knob I can make you louder okay
but all I needed to see was Tom Brady
working with Tom house yeah and that one
video right and him just working on that
right for me to realize any quarterbacks
throwing motion like a golf swing or a
shooting stroke can can become
over-reliant and become an independent
contractor at any time at any time and
it's just about perfecting the motion
yeah
Tiger Woods needs a coach I mean I don't
know what else to gotta say you guys
second greatest golfer of all time he's
needs a coach second-greatest yeah I'm
still gonna give Jack the the
championship interesting I was gonna go
third Vijay Singh Jack 118 I know I'm
same in second 19 times well that's
what's amazing about job listen I'm the
golf guy here okay I'm the one that when
they turn on the match they're gonna go
I don't know we've ever done golf on
this podcast
well definitely have one tiger tiger
like a few years ago we definitely
wanted to come golf tennis they have
some similarities to throwing tennis a
hundred that's why Josh Rosen an elite
prodigy tennis play even a battery the
same kind of thing I mean you don't see
a batter with its like front shoulder
wide open like I'm gonna hit like this
you know you keep it in there to create
the opposite Ryan Howard was super open
oh my god he would be like out I'm like
where does this power come that's why he
would miss the ball Chicago's office
yeah let's go to that one now bears
offense I don't know what you're gonna
take from that Bills game I will say
when you win 41 and 9 and then I see
that Mitchell try risky threw for less
than 150 passing rice it was a lot of
those pick sixes but where are you at
the Bears offense right I still like the
Bears offense you know again the this
Mitchell true Biscay like just waterfall
every week I've never seen a quarterback
that's under more of a microscope right
now it's it's kind of ridiculous in my
opinion you know first thing I'll say to
this just again overarching theme it was
9 to 6
Patriots over bills late in the third
quarter so first of all the bills
defense is good I think we all have to
recognize that I would argue the Bills
have one of the best defenses and they
do so it's not gonna be pretty
you know what Mitchell did it wasn't the
greatest game but Mitchell has a few
play
it's alright well you could say in a
second defense yes I was oh one game
where they let up a lot of points
Indy how many turnovers at the Bills
offense have late deep in their own zone
yeah Derrick Anderson coming off a golf
course for the same thing with the Bears
game right so like yeah there was a lot
of points against the bills yeah but it
was because they got the ball 2:30 yes
okay I'm done right and there was -
there was - there was a pick six and
then a strip fumble Eddie Jackson ya
know fumble return so yeah they're
putting a lot of tough positions so
don't just look at it that way that
defense is a handful curb risky makes a
handful of plays every game where I go
hmm that was a damn good throw or that
was a damn good run you know I still see
the potential in Mitchell drew risky I
am NOT giving up on what he is as a
person I also like the offense they do a
little bit of everything
tarik Cohen is special their old line
even without long it's been James
Daniel's going in there they're gonna be
fine there was James Davis was good he
wasn't perfect but he was good yeah and
look good in the uniform he does look
good in the uniform he's been getting in
the shuffle a little bit they play them
a little bit here and there throughout
the game so they're all lines still good
I feel like they listed the podcast and
we're like let's get Taylor Gabriel and
to recon more of a special role their
difference makers they are difference
makers and same with Anthony Miller I
felt like they were featured a lot and
they didn't get a lot of a chance to to
really get featured but I am a like a
believer in the bearers as a playoff
team like I don't think they can go to
the Superbowl obviously but I do think
that they're a pain in the butt and I
think they're a team
yeah they look out for word to be a
legit Super Bowl contender for next year
love it I'm not giving up on me I think
there's a lot of connections between the
Bears and the Eagles and where true
Biscay is and where when swari and
getting a new system and then being a
lot more comfortable to start the season
ranked G right last guy last thing to
talk about with them look girl I'm just
gonna put this on everybody's radar look
for this kid take Quan Mazzella
I don't know if I'm saying it right but
he's 510 192 he's a second year running
back out of Virginia okay and they kind
of gave him also a little bit of a Tariq
own role in the game instead of Benny
Cunningham
like Benny's got in but yeah but this
guy also lined up at like true receiver
a handful of time Negi you silly no and
he can really go like I you know you
know me I'm just watching the film I'm
gonna wait who's that guy with the three
in his jersey that's like kind of flying
down the field right here he's open like
holy [ __ ] he's really fast and I was
like okay biz oh I don't think I feel
like I've seen him in all year and he
had a little roll I just say watch out
for him Mazal alright kid sounds
interesting
you know what else sounds interesting
big Phil alright Nicky G let's get on
the lot I haven't talked in a while two
weeks I'm more than that man big [ __ ]
he's just so active on social he's too
busy tweeting because he's running his
account and his business account I think
my brother's too much time I hope a lot
of tweets coming out of the Sims outside
all I know is it's it's recording this
on a Wednesday so he's in a room
watching film yep oh hello hello
you okay Adam phillium I've missed you
two weeks two weeks has it been that
long I think it was longer I think it's
the rate I forget every year Phil they
might hated me it did write funny uh
number one happy birthday all right
happy birthday yes okay you know the old
joke um 68 I'm not 63
I don't got some funny joke no listen
it's the old thing lie up you know I'm
saying no laiá laiá because the people
say damn you look good I see I feel good
how you feeling I know I'm actually 84
you're you and my ticket you and my dad
have the same birthday really you had
November 3rd we have the same
personalities you think they both are
smart asses yeah yeah you are we are we
got a lot of issues ok do you believe in
signs no I do not
ok I'm a Taurus and what does that mean
I'm a bull which means I'm stubborn and
I'm loyal see I don't find you stubborn
I can't I don't never seen it from you
Oh trust me it's true in production
meetings like we did
oh my gosh I would be oh yeah it is his
upper lip gets big as he does it too
yeah it's really funny that's great all
right so you're stubborn as a as a mule
yes number nine is a bull bull no I like
meal better you know I know you would
the question is do you draw mules or do
you draw bulls we had our good friend
girls in in the office and how I was
asking you know what's it like to work
with big Phil and he was super
complimentary and he kept calling you
the big dog and all that stuff he did
say though that you gotta ask Phil about
what he draws on set oh no I can't do
that I draw some pictures every once
awhile you know everybody they all had
their little note cards especially bill
calorie I'll see look at this no cards
he'll leave the desk and I'll take a
card draw on it stick it in between I
watch him go through it and all of a
sudden he comes to my drawing he goes he
looks around like he sees me so whatever
you know it's pretty funny it's a really
graphic drawing and it's not nice but it
is funny
is this a drawing that you do a lot like
you've got it mastered oh yeah it's very
easy it's part of a joke so I've done it
many times is this the one where like
what does this look like and you add a
few more lines you knowing my dad and my
is it might be somebody bending over
dancing over with a soap joke because
that in fact the film may have drawn it
for me good day could be that I was a
student teaching and one kid came up
they drew and I said Woods big
expressive draw what you want the first
kid comes up and he draws the son okay
then it just goes on and on oh yeah I've
seen it yeah good you know it hits the
spot especially when we're sitting at
the desk and everybody's picking on me
and you know this and that so I just
draw it and kind of show it told the
camera can't see it that's cutting ends
that man they love to go and you Phil
that's right I think you picking on them
a lot anyway so it's big oh so wait wait
this is where I wonder I'm going to
start because we talked about this you
know you heard Dez Bryant some of the
Saints right yes
yes and the Saints going what do you
want to know well good for the Saints it
is good for the Saints is good for Dez
Bryant right
I mean he's playing with Drew Brees he
could argue is like the best 50/50 back
shoulder thrower in the history of ever
right you know son I tell you sometimes
I think that you are my son
yeah I know I'm gonna prove it right but
I did a radio show today let's see drew
brees loves to throw bike shoulders he
uh Dez Bryant can really catch them all
at this yeah I think I think just the
Saints you know the Saints we all know
Sean Payton I know him extremely well
there's nothing he's what's hill line in
the movie you know the the Russia the
Germans or Russians they never do a
thing without a plan that's Sean Payton
he's got a plan for everything and I
know they know exactly how they're gonna
use him and that's gonna be interesting
to see so okay so now the further this
conversation I told left Co you know cuz
left goes like yeah you know Drew Brees
basically invented the back shoulder
throughout and I said and I said I don't
know about that I was actually I said
actually I think I gotta give the credit
to Phil Simms yeah because I've watched
the TV tape in 1984 I believe it was 84
maybe it's 85 when you were playing the
Kansas City Chiefs right and that
football game that was 84 right and I
can remember watching I think it was
like Merlin Olsen or you know what was
the other guy Dick Enberg it was Dick
Enberg and Bob Trumpy or what the hell
is a bit trumpian burg yes but that
would have been a AFC game so we would
have been on his beat we were on NBC
right and I watched this in the house
like like a few years ago and I remember
watching it and then being like
astounded the dad kept throwing to these
receivers who were covered and throwing
it behind them and at first there were
like oh I threw it behind it was a nice
catch and then like it became a theme of
the game and they're like you know what
I think he's deliberately throwing it
behind these guys I think he knows that
the coverage is over the top and he's
deliberately stopping this is 84 1984
yes yes that's when it really started we
had wide receivers that weren't that big
and everything so we got bump and run
you know we'd have those outside routes
so I'll go if they're covered I'm
throw it behind you and we started doing
it we did it more and more and in a
course then we got mark Bavaro alright
and and then it became a Sims you know
Parcells I just want the ball I said
hell he was covered well when he's
covered remember he's open no okay I
decide thing is I understood what he was
saying and it became throw it the
defenders helmet throw it behind him
throw it here it just you do it so much
it becomes nothing so did this start in
practice and you guys came up with it
was it did it come from a coach the else
do it in the league that you're gonna
saw it yeah in 1980 I can't remember the
year exactly let me think Ronnie Earhart
people were running we saw the Miami
Dolphins run verticals right so we stole
that idea and then we put some we put
the back you know the back come out and
do whatever he wants behind it and then
we put some different routes like let's
run all verticals let's run a comeback
in case the corner you know which plays
the inside guy riding the outside got
reads it we started throwing comebacks
with it and then as people started
playing more man and man coverage
against those things that's when we
really started throwing a lot of back
shoulders and we're when crazy was in
1986 yeah
and at 85 remember going to the Provo
John Robinson was the coach and we had a
lot of great conversations he goes you
know you guys throw all those themes and
I just you know it's too risky and the
way you do it I I can't believe you
throw these balls and and of course the
story goes during the Pro Bowl he let me
put in some plays right so I put in
these plays and I'm throwing a lot of
seams and there's a timeout and I come
over was there anything you want coach
he goes yeah yeah yeah he goes throw
some more of those themes it was really
funny and it's that's kind of how it
went and in 1986 we went to Atlanta and
training camp
Fred Bruni do you remember that name I
don't afraid a great deep coordinator
for a long time in the NFL he's passed
away but he was a tremendous coach and
we were throwing back shoulders and you
know practice against them and I swear
in one you know 20-yard line going in we
scored like 13 touchdowns against their
defense and the next day we come out to
practice against the Falcons and he's
got every DB out there and there go all
right here's the back story in their
practice that's all their practices
against that I just started laughs and
he goes I'd watch the film Sims I hear
you that he was really it was really
great it was a compliment but he was so
upset because he realized after that day
because these guys are doing this on
purpose and so we kind of sold the idea
from Dan Marino but I've said that story
many times Christopher I tell people and
they don't believe me I really think we
were the first ones to really make it a
huge part of our offense right that's
awesome
yeah it's really great of course the
biggest one was Raval football Zeke
Moore two guys yeah I don't care where
you threw it
you they did not miss it I know who
would've loved those guys al Davis
this came up on Monday Phil we haven't
heard the official story
I think what's funny is if you type Phil
Simms into Google one of the first
things is rumor Al Davis
tried to hire Phil Simms it has been out
and Christopher though mentioned the
airplane ride oh yeah I mentioned just
an airplane ride I can't remember well
yeah we think we were in I think I want
to say it was like Super Bowl 30 when we
were I just said we talked about Al
Davis and I was sitting in first class
of you and mom and I remember al was
sitting like right across the aisle from
you right he was wearing his all-white
leather jumpsuit that had like
diamond-encrusted things in the Raider
emblem and I was just like this guy is
some character I was in all of it and
then we went down this stretch of where
I said you know of course I remember
growing up in Florida we would dad it we
had a house down in Jupiter Florida that
went dad liked to play golf and we had a
winter vacation or spring vacation we
would go down there for the week and I
remember like a full day or two days
stretch where man dad is in the room on
a phone with some guy for like four
hours straight each daily what the hell
is going on and he was talking about
Davis Al Davis
on that plane flight that day we talked
talked non-stop I think I don't know if
we were going to LA or where we were
going from New York yeah I think we were
coming either coming back from Super
Bowl 30 in Arizona to New York or going
out there neither one but we talked the
whole time and he must have asked me a
hundred and fifty questions of thinking
okay
only Malone now what do you think of
this coach oh and what about this player
what about this defense and he just kept
going I kept answering I kept well you
know oh and you not out mr. Davis you
know call me al you know whatever and
you know when I went out there to do
games he would bring me up into his
office and I just got here we go and we
would have to watch the film and he
would quiz me on stuff in this scenario
so this the plane flight being quizzed
in in his room sweating bullets
because I was like god I hope I don't
give him a stupid answer and when we
when I was down in Florida your mom was
listening your mom my wife or your mom
Christopher was listening in but I had
paper out and he was going okay you've
got to reduce look and they're gonna do
this blitz how do you pick it up well
here's what you do to does it uh because
I mean you know I was close enough to
being out of football why I hadn't
forgotten anything right and so I had an
answer for everything okay
and he basically said I'm gonna call you
back tomorrow I want to bring you out
here and I just want you to hang out
with me for one year and we're gonna go
over football personnel dissident and
imma hire you as the head coach that's
what he said Wow Eli you out and then
named head coach I never told anybody
because I didn't but Jim Gray because I
didn't but Jim so when Al Davis passed
away Jim Gray brought it up to somebody
yeah well Jim Gray it's like working on
our group at NBC and he knew that out
Davis was gonna do this to me I guess
they let it out so so what happened not
anymore
once you fly out interview we did it
over the phone and everything and I you
know I just I listen I get a good job
because I was afraid that's all really
what really but you were offered it and
you didn't
because you want to stay on TV right I
just didn't think I was ready I couldn't
you know I said wow that's some jump
from nowhere I don't care if you if I
study for a year then to be the head
coach you know I've never been on the
field as a coach in the NFL well that's
the reason why they just go and
immediately be the coach of the Raiders
yeah we wanted to be like a consultant
for a year and be around and he was
gonna name him the head coach the next
year right right
do you ever think back I didn't think
about it I think I was offered not
really Bill Parcells just called me out
of just this once he just said you know
Sims you're doing a great job in TV but
if you want to get into coaching I will
hire you with the Jets oh right and when
he took the jet job and I said well okay
and we talked and talked my steno is
this is true out no bill would remember
it I said okay but after three years I
want to be the head coach and he goes
you know just the bill just goes boy
you're impatient little bastard well you
know I don't know I don't want to go and
get on that journey bill and never be a
head whatever he goes well let's just
worry just you know whatever the course
I didn't come about either I don't think
he really wanted me to come and take the
job but he was gonna offer to me because
I think he knew deep down there was
something in me that might want to coach
and so I chickened out
that's all was I just never to take that
job do you have about TV it was just I
was afraid that's what it was do you
ever think what if with the Raiders job
oh yeah sure I do all the time and it
was the greatest thing I ever did is not
taking him because I've been fired
I've been on that let's go kids we're
moving to Detroit kids let's go now
we're going to Florida kids you ready
let's go again and you know that's what
would have happened I'd have been on
that train and and so you're lucky I
think guys that don't play pro football
and it turned out to be great coaches
they get such a head start on all the
stuff that goes into it and you know
that Christopher man like you you were
thinking of going into coaching but you
were so far behind some 22 year olds
right because they'd already you know
been breaking stuff down and had all the
mechanics of the job down
- or maybe a 25 yeah that kind of sucks
yeah right right that's that's a big
deal you know he's gonna coach you got
to make that decision right away and you
got to go right into it yeah Phil that
was awesome man thank you dude so I wish
I could do I used to have out Davis down
I could do it you know I did your your
Allen Davis did I ever tell you this one
no go out to do a game now we're over
that Jon Gruden is the coach night Jon
Gruden is not he goes tonight I want you
to do this for me I said yeah coach sure
coach what is it and he goes I want you
to write a report on five assistant
coaches who you think will make a good
head coach and I go oh okay I'm the girl
so that Friday night I have to go back
to the room and I sit in there all night
and write detailed notes about five
assistant coaches and you know nice and
needs and I got points and and it's like
a big thick file so I give it to Jim
Gray I think I gave it to Jim great time
he gives a dowel Davis Al Davis reads it
and he goes well this is just a bunch of
crap because because he'll I knew all
this or whatever and you know I just
remember going man that's tough lady I
really put a lot of thought work into it
all over yeah there was great great
great he was great to talk to and oh my
god I've listened I've never been around
anybody in my life and I'll let y'all go
to this that loved his players more than
Al Davis yeah I mean he Christopher you
were out there on a trip yep and he hey
he probably said it to you write about
the greatness of the Raiders were always
together all this stuff the greatness of
the Raiders brought me in and started
asking me about players on his roster
and I was like damn dude what do I tell
them the truth of that guy's not good or
what have I do I didn't know what to do
it was I'm a young kid he's like I'm
hoping this guy drafts me at the end of
the first round but that's it he did
that to me about Tyrone Wheatley and
everything like that what do you think
of this guy on my roster like that's
going off
Paul Davis inventory he quiz everybody
so Adam just imagine if he got ahold of
you you'd be like you'd lose ten pounds
of sweat time he got done with yourself
it's all good dad yeah ever done all
right good talk to you guys next week
all right see ya
we didn't talk about real football but
that was a good story honestly we can
get your dad to be like that every week
yeah it's all those are two good stories
yeah
Bendrick texted me during that and goes
Oh talked his ear off on the plane
didn't he do that to you on the way to
the Super Bowl last year he does I feel
like his impression for Bill Parcells Al
Davis and Mike Bernstein all the same
guy all right now let's get back to the
film yeah Green Bay New England oh yeah
apparently Josh walked in I walked in he
told both of us you really enjoyed
watching this film I did Josh saw
something though that he had a question
for you right so I saw I showed this to
you I saw this video on reddit today of
Belichick yelling at the refs when they
came over to tell him that he wasn't
allowed to walk out of the coach's box
the coaching area to call a timeout they
were come on guys I was like he was
guilting the refs yeah he's like I'm
just going down there to look at the
formation I'm I'm not gonna call it I
said I was thinking about calling
timeout it was the wrong formation today
and I didn't do it you know I was
waiting so my take watching this was the
coaching area exists because you're not
allowed to walk down the field and get a
better look at the formation then decide
if you want to call timeout right isn't
that rule bending if he goes down there
takes a good nice close-up look at the
formation and goes that I'm not gonna
call the time all right so what's
happening first of all you see this in
every every week in the NFL coaches run
down to the five-yard line I call the
timeout - the line judge because there's
no referee close to them right so they
can't hear they can't hear them and then
there's 80,000 people in the stadium -
so they can't be like oh you know so he
knew he was in a situation that was
dicey right and he might have been like
oh I don't know about this defense a
call here if the Packers get in this
formation I might have to call timeout
now he's going I'm going I might have to
call timeout let me go down there and
he's getting down there to call the
timeout and he's getting as he's doing
that he's going okay they're not in the
formation I'm thought they were gonna I
don't have to call the timeout it's so
gaining an advantage by being closer no
he's not okay he is not never no he's
not getting any advantage there it's
nothing like I've always told you your
best vantage point for watching a game
is 30-yard to plan anyways because you
can really see how people are lining up
the shades of the tackles all those
things so it's not and it's really
unusual for him to yell at refs
I mean that's about as yelling as he
will get he comes from the school of
Bill Parcells of reverse Jedi Mind
Tricks he treats them with great respect
and really just you be honest with me
I'll be honest with you he doesn't beg
for calls you don't see bill really get
mad at the rest very much ergo that's a
horse should call or he was he was
passed in our fear ensuing like you see
some guys or day he doesn't do any of
that he lets them rough the game and
because of that I always think that the
rest always favored him in a Bill
Parcells cuz they were great at that
they felt like oh this guy respects what
I do I respect what he does the ref in
the video looked like he felt guilty
that he had given bill a hard time
because bill is a freaking God under
full in the football world that's the
way he is like I told you back to the
owners meeting he walks into the meeting
there's a guy explaining something
extremely detailed he's late to walk in
the meeting everybody's there the guy is
making his point and Bill literally as
he's getting his bag and seat oriented
goes I don't know if I agree with that
and the guy got all flustered it was
like and he asked him a question he's
like that was a good point I'll answer
that in a minute
and I mean bill is on another level and
he's not getting an advantage though so
my take is completely wrong that bill
wouldn't go to a Dodgers game in a bye
week bill wouldn't go to a Dodgers game
who did that Jason yeah no I did have a
hard time believing that as much as bill
only think bill I could imagine him
doing on a bye week is most mr. dogs
show or like Nantucket but he's got all
his work with them and he's got a house
there or maybe he went to Miami and he's
carrying around is like ninety four
pound backpack on his one shoulder all
right so Nick Brisco sent us an email
we'd love to hear some insight from
Simms what the page
it's defense they seem to be slowly
coming into form Gilmore Trey flowers
easily to the most underrated players at
their respective positions yes the
defense overall has noticed Lee played
more aggressive under brian flatt flores
yeah interception every game except for
Green Bay appreciate it fellas
ya know the defense is I think as good
as it's been for you know a few years
I'd say in 2000 because two months ago
you said they were in deep [ __ ] yeah I
know they they're just amazing New
England they just always continue to
tinker and they got a bunch of guys back
from injury too they did that was a big
thing certainly I think it's as good a
defense as they've had since a 2014
season where they beat the Seahawks in
the Super Bowl that year that was a
pretty good D that year but yeah I mean
Trey flowers I think I wrote in my notes
he's got the greatest hands and
Collinsworth pointed this out in the
game and I totally agree with it
he's gaming Dante you said yeah
unbelievable hands in the pass rush you
just really got to be careful if you're
a guard or a tackle and you think you're
gonna like give them the punch and stop
them and they're ready for it and they
will could do a lot of different type of
moves double hand slaps win moves
whatever it may be to get you off
balance but phenomenal those two like he
hit a spot on I think it's a combination
of other corners who really helped I
really like the JC Jackson kid you did
and wrote that and I could tell they
liked him because they put him in
situations where I go they wouldn't put
him in there if they didn't think that
he was really capable there him the
Jonathan Jones kid at nickel is
extremely impressive so he does a good
job a course McCourty is still one of
the best safeties in football and you
know Kyle van Noy
in the middle like a hide shower right
they can do a little bit of everything
is gilmore a top-five corner right now I
need to look at like and just think sit
down and think about it but Gilmore but
yeah I guess I'm just kind of using that
as a phrase yeah no I don't Gilmore a
top corner he is a top corner in
football yes he is he's asked to play on
an island on a consistent basis against
the number one or number rejected Avante
he did phenomenal I mean phenomenal I
mean
Devante was not a factor when Stephen
Stephon Gilmore covered him that's you
know again it goes to my point where I
started to say like you know
receivers aren't as good as people think
they are they just see the stats and
they see a touchdown on a big game of
their and Rogers like wow that was good
I just remind everybody guys like James
Jones led the NFL on touchdown
receptions when they played with Aaron
Rodgers and then they couldn't even get
a pass thrown to them and on other teams
and they went there so yes that was
nothing for him interesting thing that
Gilmore did I thought throughout the
game was during in the field for the
most part he and they wanted to play
man's he shadowed Davante Adams when
they got down to like the 20 25 yard
line I felt like they switched him to
Valdez scantling a few they did I think
because of his size and length and they
are afraid they're afraid Rodgers gonna
throw him a back shoulder or a jump ball
and Gilmore it's a big corner and he can
compete with that type of play that's
New England they're on another level all
right so there was a few good nuggets in
here you did right the Pats offense
started so fast early that the film
couldn't keep up couldn't keep up what
does that mean it means that when
there's it after a play is over it goes
to the scoreboard and shows you okay now
it's second and seven and here's the
time on the clock and you get to see
that between every cut of every play
well this was like a bore it was like it
was like it was first and ten they run
the play and it also that came back to
like I mean I did the quickest screen
shot you could ever imagine like the
camera just went up and went back down
and because they were getting ready and
you didn't even get to see the start of
the play sometimes like the ball was
already snapped everybody was just
getting it fast as you seen the Patriots
rather it was up there yeah it was it's
a new staple yeah if you're playing a
young secondary or a young defense hurry
up hurry up it's what they do he he just
he just fought he's just gonna find a
flaw that he goes I gotta see I think
every big game they just do the hurry up
they do not know what who's gonna play
to the spate of bricks Peter Brady
exactly right it's the greatness of what
they can bring to the table it's either
to confuse a secondary who's
overcomplicated and he wants to put
their checks to test their youngness to
the test or they have great pass rushers
and he wants to wear them out by running
a lot of plays no rpoS for Pats
they first coach it the old-fashioned
way yeah I wanted to say this for a
while like yeah the past don't run rpoS
you know what they do they do they they
coach their team to go we're gonna pull
the guard and they
look like the same run okay but we're
really gonna pass protect but we make it
look like the run everyone says no one
doubts does that and not a lot of teams
do that in football because it's too
hard to put all the protection that you
might need to do against the different
fronts with a guard pulling and all
those things and still have to pass Pro
well they do it I just thought it was
interesting in this RPO era that's how
people do they're like play-action
passes out of the shotgun for the most
part New England still doing it the
old-fashioned way
Jair Alexander is some player and Josh
Gordon is an effing free gosh I mean
Josh Gordon yeah I mean he's the best
receiver on the field I mean he seems
yeah better yeah Josh Gordon is better
than Davante Adams definitely yes sorry
I don't know what else to say
I mean Jacques de Monte Adams is not
capable of doing what Josh Gordon can do
you know and I'm not saying it's like
like by a longshot where I just got he's
so much better that's disrespectful
but yeah Josh Gordon his speed his
ability to leap into the air and he has
the best hands on the field almost
weekly yeah he's a true weapon I mean he
really is that's a good one yeah uh and
then Patriots D disguises Patriots Oh
disguises are under no d disguise unreal
they are actually doing double disguise
although this guy this is where I got
cool with the the Rogers safety thing
you're talking about we've always wanted
to know about Rogers versus Belichick
right so Belichick you've never seen him
without a devil disguise before now they
were so what does that mean it means all
right so they were very you know this I
felt like the game plan was a little
similar to like Patrick mahomes in
Kansas City not that it was exactly
similar but same thing they were gonna
do their best and never let Rodgers get
comfortable their offense is not very
creative and complicated like I've told
you but they do what they do and Rodgers
is smart to go at least like hey this
simple dumb play we got works against
this and I'll make it work okay that's
what they do but of course you know
Bill's not gonna let Rogers just God
they're free willing and put them in the
perfect play that he sees fit every play
so they were doing double sky cz's and
to paint a picture for everybody like
let's say McCourty and Darren Harmon are
down there like okay we might put
and then and then right as they thought
Rogers gonna snap snap out of it they
backed out like they were gonna go to
cover to but then but then when he did
snap it they didn't go to cover to and
they went single safety and one of the
safeties went down to play like cover
three or rub or man robber right so they
went to that extent to go like like we
want you to disguise but we want you to
fake like you do another defense and
then when the ball is actually snap you
got to get back into the defense we're
calling you to do that put them at a
disadvantage again okay okay definitely
can like cuz you're delayed in getting
to where you need it
exactly right you're rolling the dice
but bills taking a calculated risk on a
certain third down situation or he sees
fit and he goes you know what I mean if
they got the right play dialed up here
and they get us some hey they get us but
I feel better knowing that Rodriguez is
like oh crap I don't know what this is
and then he might take a second getting
the ball in his hand and reading the
defensive going like wait what what is
going on here they just showed this and
that's not that now and now you you're a
late to a first read or a second read or
whatever happens and you wrote
cordarrelle Patterson is an official
running back facial like it's like ty
Montgomery but way better you know this
is this is where he was meant to be and
the fact that they have the vision for
that is phenomenal yeah I just think he
is like we talked about on Monday
he's like a faster latavius Murray he's
got a natural knack for finding the hole
he runs hard as hell and I would be
shocked if he is not the second running
back or at least the 1a and 1b to Sony
Michele for the rest of the year he's
proven to me that he can do it at it
like a at a high level I picked him up
on our fantasy team good nice pickup
good I hope so oh just kind of wrapping
it up a little bit since I think a lot
of people use our betting show but want
to get this out before the game yeah
Panther Steelers yeah
in Pittsburgh yeah interesting matches
I'm breaking this down with caddy out
there as a Steelers fan and I'm thinking
you know the Steelers and the Panthers
really match up well with each other
right because you know James Connor
underneath you have two linebackers to
the Panthers that can kind of work on it
juju and Antonia are gonna have to find
the holes in that Carolina zone
and we'll see what happens the times
they do go man the Carolina defensive
line the Pittsburgh offensive line is
gonna be a really nice battle the entire
game yeah other side of the ball
I do think Carolina has an advantage
yeah I do think that Greg Olson and
Christian McCaffrey if I had to pick one
wholeness dealers it's that line backing
core if I'm ever getting ISO with an
Olson of Vince Williams or something
like that
Carolina's kind of works inside out but
I do know that the Steelers have a lot
of weapons that are gonna be able to run
with the DJ Moors and the Curtis Samuels
of the world and the Christian
McCaffrey's but it's that middle of the
defense that I'm wondering and then it
always comes down to when cam runs are
the two it's in the Hayward of the world
gonna be able to keep him the pot guy
cuz he starts running on the outside but
the other thing is too it's it's a big
primetime game in Pittsburgh yeah and
when it's a primetime game in Pittsburgh
yeah I always kind of go Steelers yeah
what do you how does this game kind of
play out to you I mean I feel the same
way that the Steelers are you know I
would pick the Steelers to win the
football game I think it's incredibly
close I think this Panther offense will
really test this Pittsburgh defense this
will be the biggest test they've had for
since maybe Kansas City if maybe I'm
missing somebody in there but I think so
as of complete ncinnati yeah I think
this is a tougher offense because of the
cam because of the you know I don't I
would be shocked if the Pittsburgh
Steelers can just simply overpower
Carolina up front like they've done
Carolina is pretty good at they got some
big strong guys who can hold their
ground but I think because it is in
Pittsburgh I have a hard time also
thinking that Carolina's pass-rush can
get home against Big Ben in them that
yeah they win a 23-20 2421
23:21 type of football game that's how I
would envision it going you think it
would be close I do I mean I would not
be shocked if Carroll I like if I'm a
better and everybody's listening for
that aspect I would say don't bet on
this game I mean this is this is I mean
you can go either way these teams are
very good and they have a lot of
similarities and playing style that's
similar as far as they kind of want to
be the more physical bullies on the team
and they both have quarterbacks who it
doesn't matter if they're
home or on the road or on planet Mars
they're not gonna be like worried about
the atmosphere around them I just think
my issue with the Steelers is I don't
really see the great cover linebackers
yeah and I'm just thinking about
McCaffrey and all those guys that's a
real question my only question would be
is are we using the edmonds of the world
and the secondary athletes that you
talked about on Monday right to cover
those guy yes they could you know I
think more they're not they can't live
in man to man how does it been do
against the zone defense it's pretty
damn good really I mean Ben is like like
Cam and Carson Wentz they are just
unfazed by people around them they're
unfazed doesn't matter my back I don't
care I could still throw that any kind
of you know they're just it's so nothing
intimidates them that way where it's
just it never matters but yeah I think
maybe because of somewhat of the
simplicity of Carolina's defense a
little too that I got to give the
advantage of Pittsburgh but um this is
my favorite Thursday night matchup of
the year so far for sure
other than Nick Mullens against the
Raiders you're sure you didn't enjoy
Giants Eagles I was a doozy that was it
was cool because we get to see Carson
get back in the default and was good
Rams Rams was good that was the Thursday
of the year so far yeah it was the best
say that was the first that was the only
time me and Josh have watched a few
Thursday nights together I'm too cool
for school without one we actually went
out for I think we're gonna go out for
this Thursday - okay well when I don't
have a Notre Dame MIT week maybe I'll do
that with you guys soon I'll be fun yeah
for Sims peace out homies go get some
well-done steaks not vendrick would say
good evening everybody and the lef koe
man will say I need to make better bets
Sims gap has widened oh thank you I
cannot allow this to be the year you
finally beat me I'm gonna study up hard
alright go Paul right see you guys later
holla holla holla